it's it's it's always weird for me
watching american reality tv show versus
british reality tv show because i feel
like british reality tv show is like
so much more toned down than american
like i think
i think when i think of british reality
tv shows the the peak that comes to me
is something like
come dine with me that's pretty good or
like
what's the other one that that [ __ ]
guy does where you just come up to him
at a table and he's buy
[ __ ] off you for like a hundred quid was
the antique hunters or something
oh antiques roadshow antique roadshow is
that is that it oh i like that i like
that
yeah i've been on the air for like i
don't know how long and it's just fun to
watch
people to bring in some things i'll give
you [ __ ] 20 quid for it yeah it's
like the [ __ ] you know like porn
stars right but like legitimate
like more legit than that yeah yeah come
down with me is probably
probably the best british reality show i
think i enjoy it
one of my favorite trash reality tv
shows on engl i can't remember the name
but the concept is they take this couple
who you know doesn't have a lot of money
but are wanting but want to get married
oh my god i want to get married it's
like an ackee lobster
yeah not cheap as weddings that's the
australian is that the australian
australian voters and they get like they
give them 10k to sort out this wedding
right oh it's uh
uh i'm like the bride has no control she
yeah she doesn't know anything and it's
all up to the guy is obsessed with that
show
it was a bbc three show yeah yeah yeah
and uh who called the bride or something
like
something like something like that who
wants the bride who wants to write
something like that
but it's such a it was such a good
concept in my opinion because like 10k i
feel like is
just the right amount of money to be
able to make a wedding happen but
not enough to make everything you want
out of a wedding happening well that's
pretty genius yeah it's it's
genius and like making the guy do it as
well yeah i mean you don't need
producers right you just sit there and
follow the guy
if he does nothing that's fantastic
content yeah he's like
and they must be fully aware of it too
because they always shoot they always
choose to use the 10k
in the worst [ __ ] we should have done
that with dance weddings
because the guys in the show right the
first thing they do it's like call up
the crew
yeah and they call it like their boy
they call up their boys and they're like
and then like the main guy will be
[ __ ] clueless and then that one
friend is like i really don't think you
should
you know hire inflatable dinosaurs for
your wedding that seems like a bad idea
like no no i got this that's why you're
waiting there's always
there's either the guy who like there
was never a guy who got it like 100
right because
yeah there was a guy who was like pretty
close and then like did a modest attempt
and there was just the other type of guy
that was like
i'm gonna do [ __ ] star wars themed
weddings
my favorite one is the one where like
the the the groom like
decides to get married in like a pig
barn oh yes yeah i've seen this one like
they go to like
the dead like a farm with like [ __ ]
muddiest yeah
i i think it's like but you love pigs i
think i saw one where the guy
like hosted the wedding in a cave like a
proper
an actress okay yes if you're not caving
yeah yeah
i mean that's that's badass but then
like you're not in the nutty buddy like
he knew that the bride's mum was
claustrophobic
so the bride's not match he couldn't
attend like the wedding ceremony because
he was like standing outside
the cave that's [ __ ] big brain that's
so big
yeah so uh my in-laws hate boats so i
decided let's get on the cruise
i mean as someone who's like planning a
wedding now it's it's it's great for me
because i'm just like
i i see the stress that people complain
that people can make a survey to like
sydney's family so what are your fears
yeah what are you afraid of we're doing
like zoos like
it's like my favorite moment is always
when they try to pick the dress
it's like it's not even like a little
bit wrong it's always the complete
opposite of what the bride picks it's
literally like m123 and have a breakdown
have a mental breakdown right now start
crying stop telling me
the wedding's over that's literally how
it looks